déconfinement en espagne également les
terrasses et les plages ont rouvert
progressivement en début de semaine la
réouverture des frontières elle est
prévue pour le mois de juillet une
nécessité selon certains pour un pays
qui compte énormément sur la saison
estivale et son lot de touristes
on va voir ce reportage avec la déco et
aurélie chamois les 17 hectares du parc
guell à barcelone voit défiler en temps
normal pas moins de 3 millions de
visiteurs chaque année
selon les chiffres de 2010 est autorisé
à se promener depuis un mois les
barcelonais se réapproprie petit à petit
le deuxième site touristique le plus
visité de la ville une année noire pour
le secteur mais cette absence de
visiteurs ravis tout de même certains
riverains qui redécouvre les trésors de
leur patrimoine
cela fait dix ans que je n'étais pas
venu pourquoi parce que d'habitude c'est
rempli de touristes et il ya beaucoup de
monde
alors maintenant on profite qui n'est
pas de tourisme on peut venir et en
profiter d'une autre manière
quand il y à des touristes et les bons
sont tellement plein tellement remplie
de gens qu'on te donne pas voir la vue
derrière les bancs alors oui c'est bien
plus agréable maintenant que quand il y
a du monde prend plus on a l'impression
qu'ils se battent pour avoir toujours la
meilleure place
aujourd'hui tu as pas besoin de te
battre je pense que la mairie devrait
apprendre à restreindre davantage
l'entrée aux touristes et laisser les
parcs dont nous profitons tous depuis
que nous sommes petits pour les
barcelonais
il n'y a que la partie du haut du parc
qui est gratuite habituellement mais là
où nous sommes maintenant il faut payer
normalement il faut payer pour entrer
c'est juste pour les touristes pas pour
les gens d'ici depuis plusieurs années
le tourisme de masse inquiète les
barcelonais et suscite l'hostilité de
certains habitants plusieurs
manifestations ont déjà eu lieu pour
dénoncer les incivilités des visiteurs
et une municipalité qui favorise le
bien-être des touristes au détriment de
ses habitants pilier de l'économie
locale le secteur touristique représente
12 % de l'économie catalane
problème depuis le 15 mars le tourisme
est au point mort alors pour tenter de
sauver la saison estivale le pr
ministre espagnol pedro sanchez a
décrété samedi la réouverture des
frontières dès le mois de juillet pour
accueillir les touristes étrangers